good evening good evening members and
welcome to this meeting of the
council i am councillor adrian osborne
chairman of baba district council and i
will be chairing this meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the ipswich town football club
training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this formal meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of this meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consent is being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for all webcasting
and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies from councillors grandin
hardacre mccraw plum carpendale and none
and cancer davies and councillor gould
are as we've already previously heard
stuck in traffic and may not get here
declarations of interest by councillors
in accordance with the delegated
authority the monitoring officer has
granted dispensation to all members in
respect of the 22 23 budget papers
do we have any other declarations
nope i'll carry on then
item three bc 2129 too
oh sorry
sorry mr chairman yeah i declare um i'm
a trustee of the assistance advice in
sudbury
thank you council osborne
councillor mayberry
thank you mr chairman i also declare
that i'm a director of a citizen's
advice
for sudbury and district thank you
thank you councillor mayberry
um
right item three
to
bc 2129 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 2nd of february 2022
for accuracy only
the minutes have been circulated are
there any issues of for with accuracy
could i have a proposal please
thank you councillor haran
could i have a second to please
thank you councillor arthi
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair as this is a consensus
vote i am asking for a show of hands all
of those in favor please
thank you chair that is carried
thank you that is carried
item four
i would like to invite councillor ward
to make his announcements
thank you chairman
firstly i'm pleased to say i don't have
anything to report about covid fingers
crossed does seem to be abating and we
really can look forward to a better year
and see more of us working back here in
endeavour house
on a matter of housing i just wanted to
provide a brief update on our hra as we
will be considering the budget for it in
a short while
so far
we have added this this financial year
we have added 94 new homes
to our own housing stock including the
recently announced completions in
shopping brampton bringing the total for
the past seven years to 228.
our retrofitting program to improve
insulation install new heating systems
and address damp and mold is proceeding
well and significant progress can now be
seen
on the springlines estate and sudbury
phase one involving 39 properties has
been completed and phase two will start
in the spring involving 28 more
properties
final phase 3 will address about another
30 properties
in addition we are installing external
wall insulation and replacement windows
elsewhere in the district
we are completing a desktop study into
the energy performance of our housing
stock and aligning our ambitions to
improve the worst performing homes to an
epc rating of sea or above
indications are that the works required
will affect approximately 2 700 homes
i was very pleased to be able to go on
radio suffolk just over a week ago to
talk about the money we have been
awarded from the government's new rough
sleepers accommodation program
this will allow us to build specialized
emergency accommodation units for those
who have been excluded and marginalized
due to complex needs
and will add to the existing 80
temporary units and 11 rough sleeper
units our two districts already have
this latest round of funding will also
allow us to build on the work made
possible due to the previously
successful rough sleeper initiative
funding bid which was used to create a
dedicated outreach and mental health
support service for rough sleepers
our towns are getting busier and
business does seem to be picking up for
many vacancy rates at 10 in sudbury and
11.6 in hadley are lower than the
national average which is clearly due to
the greater prevalence of small
independence rather than change stores
last week we informed you that the
digital skills program initially
launched for businesses on virtual high
street is now open to all businesses in
the districts this is part of our post
covered recovery strategy and has been
run by mentor using funding from the
suffolk inclusive growth investment fund
the program is based on virtual
workshops which are free to attend that
cover topics such as online security
digital and social media marketing
e-commerce and information management
the past two years have demonstrated
that these skills together with a strong
online presence which the virtual high
street has provided for the first time
for many businesses in our towns are no
longer nice to haves for businesses they
are essential to enable them to survive
and thrive
along with our innovate local scheme and
innovation labs our councils are
providing real and valuable support for
our businesses
the work at gainesville's house in saint
peter's and sudbury are proceeding well
with a former schedule to open soon
our artistic and cultural heritage in
the district is strong and in the
suffolk free press last week james
cartilage again reinforced the desire to
build a joined up offering that also
includes benton end in hadley and
flatfoot mill
last week i was pleased to visit the
latest venture in sudbury's art scene
the new voluptus gallery that has been
widely featured recently on tv and in
the press
i had a good chat with the owner about
her plans and ambitions and i really
hope
she will be successful
the eastern gateway business park at
sprawton that is borough council owns is
seeing further development with part of
it sold for construction of five
industrial and logistical units
although tenants have not been
identified yet the purchaser who has a
program of acquisition of development
sites along the a14 is confident that
the units will be occupied quickly
there is a growing demand particularly
for logistics units we must ensure that
economic growth is not held back by end
by an inability to satisfy this demand
through a lack of identified sites
you'll be aware that babe and mid-south
district councils have invited the local
government association to carry out a
corporate peer challenge
these are sector-led improvement reviews
undertaken by councillors and officers
from councils from elsewhere in the
country
the peer review team will be visiting us
between the 14th and 16th of march
the process involves engaging with a
wide range of people connected with the
councils and many of you will be
involved in the process through
participation in focus groups
the peer review
sorry the peer review team will be
looking for your considered honest and
constructive feedback
so please do highlight good practice but
also those areas for improvement and
challenge
the team will also be conducting site
visits to sudbury and stow market
and finally
we can't have a baber meeting without at
least one mention of parking but this
time it is good news
the new machines have been successfully
installed last week at both sudbury and
hadley car parks customers can now pay
for parking using coins debit or credit
card contactless or
my permit
application user guide videos have been
produced and will be shared on social
media and our website
thank you chairman
right two points forward
yes councillor barrett
i think uh john you were going to
mention a memorial service
i don't know if you'd like to do that
sorry yes
there is a memorial service on the 28th
of march for uh councilman nick ridley
at laven church 3pm
thank you melanie for sorry melanie
um my item five to receive notifications
and petitions in accordance with the
council procedures
oh councilman
well if if i may mr chairman um this is
not a question i would actually just
like to say that i think that the
refurbishment on springlands
is a good improvement and i actually
like them
and i think to have um
they were all dark before but now
they've got sort of brighter colored
um render i think it's it's a good
improvement and i think
whoever has done that gavin i'm going to
say should be congratulated because i
think it's a vast improvement well done
right
move on to item five to receive
notification petitions in accordance
with council procedure rules
thank you chair we have received a
validated petition regarding planning
application dc 21 06519
bellevue house sudbury
this petition will be dealt with through
the usual planning processes thank you
chair
thank
a you item six questions by the public
in accordance with council procedure
rules
non-received chair thank you
item seven questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedure rules
non-received chair thank you
i'd now like to go to item 8
ov scrutiny committee report
i'd like to invite councillor mclaren to
introduce paper bc 2130 which is for
noting
thank you
thank you chad
members have received this
um obviously this overview and scrutiny
meet him was in preparation for
the council meeting today and we were
happy to
know the
draft general fund
and the draft housing revenue account
i'm happy to take any questions
um are there any questions for class or
mclaren
counselor maybe
um thank you very much mr chairman um i
refer members to page nine top of page
nine first paragraph
um i'm actually very concerned about
this statement
about what
accommodation has been used for the
victims
of domestic abuse
i understood from my dealings within
this sector
this was completely
anonymous
and i'm very concerned that that has
been included
and i'd like an explanation please
um
that was raised as a question
during the discussion council of maybe
i'm not quite sure what is confidential
about it
um thank you mr chairman what is
confidential about this is if there is a
perpetrator who's absolutely insistent
on finding an ex-partner and they see
this and they know that that person is
somewhere in suffolk they will draw the
records to try and find that person and
this should not be put in here anything
to do with domestic abuse
is completely confidential
everything is anonymous
yes we do have refuges within suffolk
but i can assure you nobody knows where
they are and if they do i haven't hope
that nobody actually ever mentions it
this is absolutely wrong
and it should be removed from the
details thank you
thank you
thank you chair um
i'm not sure that was the intention of
the discussion at the meeting i would
like some advice actually from
and what you would like me to do with
this report
chair if um that was in the meeting and
it was an open meeting
at that time then actually it's in the
public domain i we can't withdraw what
is already in the open part of the
meeting unfortunately um
so
it's as it is if it was in an open
report then it stands on the agenda
thank you
thank you i'm going i am really going to
pursue this um i think sean's just
taking off again um thank you i'm going
to pursue this because
this is not how the system works
and this is really serious news and
there should be somebody here
sadly
councillor nuns knops here councillor
davis is not here whoever is looking
after domestic abuse these days
they need to have
taken this out as soon as it was
mentioned
within um a meeting
it should have been clamped down on and
should never ever have been reported
this is really serious news
and those that are following
um domestic abuse i can't think of a
name at the moment dame somebody or
other um she
she will go the berserk at baber i'm
sorry to pursue it but this should never
have been reported at all
chair thank you thank you councillor we
of course will have a look into it and
report back to you thank you
and it's a question probably to margaret
may bruce that's all right i mean i'm
reading this and i can't see that that
actually gives a precise location
of where somebody is i can't see that in
this
ons report a minute
uh yes if i could concur with councillor
arty actually i mean i've dealt with a
number of places like this and it says
quite clearly
um it's using some of the housing stock
as temporary accommodation it's very
open-ended it says units of domestic
violence so what we don't want to do i
would suggest is dramatic dramatizing
something in here i think counselor um
mcleod sorry
um
mclaren forgive me um it's quite right
in uh i don't think there's anything we
need to take this any further
i i i
and i'm agree totally with what council
art he says on this
we'll look into that thank you
any other question should play some
mclaren
okay
um
council arthi
yeah i've got one um
and it's to do with the the
consideration by committee of the budget
and i notice in here it says that rns
considered a zero council tax increase
budget
is that right or was the concept of a
plus two percent
introduced at the meeting as well and if
so why isn't it minuted
maybe i can answer that
the papers were put forward um to the
ons
we were putting the papers forward and
at that stage the whole budget had been
uh calculated on a zero percentage
increase so that was what was given to
ons to look at
um at that stage
uh then came back and obviously then we
had
further looks but it was we had a
slightly different term time frame uh
which meant that
the uh
ons committee had a papers before that
we had actually gone through to the
final decision-making of where we were
i'd like now to go to item 9
recommendations from cabinet and
committees
let's carry on
item 9a
bc 2131 general fund budget 2122 and
four year outlook
i would like to invite council about to
introduce paper bc 2131
and to move the recommendation in the
report as this is a complex paper i am
minded to allow
councillor about additional time to
introduce this his report
uh thank you mr chairman um hopefully i
will be a fairly quick this obviously
has had plenty of airing it's been to
ons it's been the cabinet
um and also the papers have been
generally um
distributed to members of the council
but uh to just give a bit of background
this year we've taken a slightly
different approach hence
why we were looking at
zero we worked started on a zero base
increase
looking forward and taking the budget
in a slightly different way
it's been quite clear over a number of
years the budget's been presented
in quite a sort of i would say cautious
away
which has resulted year in year of us
having
a significant underspend on the out-turn
figures
so you have to then question whether
we are looking at the budget in the
right way
so there was an emphasis this year to
actually have a slightly more
um uh
entrepreneurial approach i would say
to to the budget
so we would where areas have been very
risk-averse we were introducing a little
bit more risk
and looking at those figures
basically there is no point in us coming
with a budget showing a very poor
picture to the council every year and
then at the out turn we're having a big
surplus that surely is not correct so
what we're trying to do is actually look
at the budget see where we have
pressures on spending look at those and
then see where we can prove
that that position to get the budget in
a more accurate position
so we came
to
the initial position
which
showed about a 402
000 pound surplus without any council
tax increase on the zero budget those
are the figures that went to ons which
is counter arthur has pointed out
um
so looking at those figures and then
taking into account the
medium-term financial position which is
obviously where we were it still showed
a um
budget deficit position in year 4 of 2.3
million
so bearing that in mind and once we've
actually gone
and committed ourselves to a
budget position
we then
looked at those figures and felt that we
shouldn't
go with a zero percentage increase
we could go with a five pound per
month per annum increase
what we thought we'd do is to keep it
below inflation at two percent which
gives us a in band d uh 3.48
per annum increase or 29 pence per month
that is to keep our budget position in a
fairly sensible way looking forward
bearing in mind we have the media term
financial position which
is an out turn of 2.3 million deficit
so that enabled with a two percent
increase that gives us a an extra 120
000 which is where we are sitting at the
moment in the budget that's before you
with a um
527 000
surplus for year 2223
that is a fairly
good position to be in it's not
excessive
it covers us for any eventualities
but also within the budget
what also been noticeable
we are not spending our capital program
our capital program keeps having carry
forwards year in year out
that um is something that we really need
to address it basically means we are not
actually delivering on projects that we
know we've got coming forward
i would like to see that go so
rather than next year i'd rather not see
large
carry forwards
on the basis of that also we have
in our reserve we
continually have a 12
or in the past we have a 12 reserve
which is our rainy day fund that's real
cash in the bank 1.2 million
bearing in mind for the last two years
we've probably gone through the worst
period we've ever gone through in terms
of
our rainy day fund
we did not touch it
it didn't
it was not used
so bearing in mind that we also have
a lot of
activities and
communities
in our district
who are worthy
what we've done is put
200 000 from that reserve
into the community's grants fund
that means that
organizations within weber can bid
for that extra 200 000
it's there to help them
as part of
i would think the code recovery and
other areas that we we actually then
have that available for them to beat for
i think that's a very sensible approach
it doesn't cost us any money
uh it's coming out of a stagnant budget
which i think will be
which will be good for our communities
so what i would say
we have
taken
a slightly less risk-averse approach
the reserve at 10
is perfect within parameters
and we should not really be worried
about that
and obviously i had to get that past
catherine
as our 151 officer
and she was very content with that
position
so basically um
i would like uh to
propose
item 3
3.1 3.2
um and i would ask for a second
i now like to go to uh questions
members can ask as many questions
as they wish but they must be relevant
to the subject that's being discussed
and and and
it must be a question
thank you who would like to start
council jameson
uh thank you chair i've um just got
three questions for council barrett if
you could
um help firstly the premises costs
do these include the ongoing costs
um
of court lane
and if so could he tell me what those
ongoing costs are for those premises
uh the second question
the second question
um
counselor barra
always puts a caveat in when it comes to
reducing climate change and biodiversity
impact it's always the cabinet of where
financially viable
could you tell me why he does that why
he doesn't do that i mean there's
we don't provide a better service for
our customers when financially available
we don't tackle homelessness when
financially available so why is it
always a caveat when it comes to climate
change that we only do it when
financially viable
and um the third question if you could
um
help me is um
are the residents of the likes of
shotley brentham pinewood paying in
their increased council tax so that he
can protect
conservative seats in hadley and sudbury
thanks a lot thank you
um
the
climate change
would you give someone an open check
with no benefit
because that's what you're asking me to
do and i would say no
i would want benefits climate change yes
i totally agree with it we've got a
climate emergency it's more of a 111 not
a 999
but actually i think
you wouldn't do it with an open check
so that's all i'm saying
i totally recognize there are things but
also we are limited in what we can do
so where we can make a difference
i think we should be doing it and
actually we should do it well
but not with an open check because if
we're putting our public money into a
something and it's public money it's not
someone's pet subject
um so we've got to uh really look at
that and say
if we put that in what's the out turn
what's the benefit to our residents who
are paying for it and that's my caveat
your point about the shotley peninsula
and those other people
okay so let's look at how much goes into
the coffins of baby district council
from shotley peninsula and burners and
all those places around there compared
with say sudbury great cornard which is
our major economic hub
it doesn't compare they put millions in
shot the ganges puts 1.5 million in
total they put 10 12 million in so to
say they're cross subsidising i think is
a absolute
it doesn't stack up
thank you mr chairman i i must admit i
would uh have to disagree with
councillor barat on his last point there
but uh we won't go down that route at
the moment i've got too many other
things here to to ask him about
he mentioned that
in the past we've been rather too
cautious with our budgets
but paragraph 5.8 on page 24
talks about in recent years the council
has tended to underspend the budget that
has been set the reasons for this have
been reviewed and it's generally been
due to additional income
being received rather than expenditure
proposals not being achieved so it's not
that we're not spending money we're just
earning more but that doesn't mean that
we've got to go out and spend it so
perhaps he would like to comment on
why we should be forced to spend money
just because it's coming in
when
all of our residents of course are
having a tough time trying to earn some
money to come in
uh secondly
uh
5.12 page 24 again
it talks about the council's net cost of
services for 2223
going up by 414
000 pounds
and yet further on in the document we
are talking about the three wonder
wonders
of
reinvent and where are we can't find it
now oh here we are review remodel and
reinvent which we seem to talk about
every year but it doesn't nothing seems
to get reviewed remodeled or reinvented
and yet our costs are going up i did ask
at a recent workshop for
figures on
total number of employees and the total
uh
salary bill but i hadn't seen anything
on it yet it was noted on the chief
executives
summary of the of the meeting but
nothing's been done about it or appears
to be done about it
uh
also uh
the well-being reserve that is mentioned
on page 31
which is the 200 000 that's coming out
of the general fund reserve while we
reduce it from 1.2 million to 1 million
going to a well-being
reserve he talked to council barrack
talked about a community's
budget an increased expenditure
expenditure on communities
but on page 33 the chart there of thor
cart forecaster budget gaps etc it
doesn't show any increase in community
funding at funding herb expanding
uh to the extent of 200 000
so is this as has been intimated by
council jameson
a particular fund for particular
purposes bearing in mind that there's an
election in just under 12 just over 12
months
and so i'd like an answer on that one
first i've got some more questions but
i'll let some him answer those and then
i'll have a few more later on if i may
mr german
within that statement but um
oh there's some questions in there i
just
so
spending money um
right well being reserved well that's
that's been put in because that's voted
in as part of our
um
strategic priorities
so that's clearly within there
um the the fund is
for
grants to
organizations so it's in our it's in our
grant program where organizations can
bid for that
across the district
and there was another question somewhere
i can't remember what it was
sorry which cost
staff cost going up 417.
well i thought staff cost had gone up
considerably more than that because
clearly we've also introduced where
we've now taken back id verdi
um so the staff costs
that are likely to come in
the net cost well there's also um
[Music]
changes in the grant and reserve funds
of 683
there's also the base
uh increase of 155 plus pay and pensions
increase as well
i mean the difference if you're looking
at the grocery because there's 1.7
million
662 of that is also made up of the
public realm coming back into labour
where that was on cid verdi so there are
increases there
we should expect
which one staffing staffing right yes
i'm happy thank you just happy to come
in on the question that council hints
and asked about staffing has made
reference to a question that was opposed
to me uh that we're absolutely right
counselor hints and asked that question
and asked it to be included within a
future report obviously that report
hasn't yet been written but i've got the
figure so happy to share them tonight if
that's useful so as of january so as of
the middle of last month baby mid
suffolk combined because of course it's
a shared workforce
employ
579 officers that's a full-time
equivalent of 525 officers because
obviously not everyone is a full-time
employee and the combined salary costs
including on costs of those staff is
just over 21 million pounds
well-being
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um i've got a few
questions but i may come back a bit
later with some of them um first of all
i'd just like to thank councillor
barrett uh for being in charge of our
finances he's certainly very helpful to
be
very open and transparent and trying to
do a very good job
um
a couple of hims
am i right in thinking that in our
second quarter
we had a 320 000 pound surplus
that's one question
and um
if
if that's correct
why are we increasing to council tax at
all when we've got
a surplus
and i think
in our third
quarter
it could possibly go up
i mean i suppose it could go down but um
hopefully you'd be able to tell us
whether you think it's going to go down
or up but certainly at this moment in
time we do have this surplus
also
we're paying an additional
41 000 pounds to senior officers
this
i assume is in this budget somewhere
unfortunately the papers arrive late i
got my two minutes to one today that's
no fault of the council
we had no postage on tradie
but so i had the chance to go through
the paperwork
but
i would have done but if that's there
then i believe this
is also um before inflation so um not
only do the
workforce get an inflation uh increase
they would get this extra 41 000
um i don't think we can afford that
um the other thing
the
um
five hundred thousand pounds which was
uh earmarked to go for
um refurbishment of our office rooms
here i assume uh which we only
contribute in half because the other
half will go to mid-suffolk 250 000
pounds do we really need to do that do
we need to spend as much money as that
i haven't seen the paperwork on that
either
so
um
you know
all these things are happening they're
not the things that are benefiting the
man in the street who's going to foot
this bill at the end of the and women
sorry and who's going to foot this bill
at the end of the day
so i think that that isn't very good
um
yes i've got some other things but i'll
stop there and see how we get on with
some of the answers thank you mr
chairman
our chief executive to answer that
question on staff
again thank you chairman i just wanted
to come in on the staffing one council
vote i'm sure it's perfectly capable of
answering it but it's as it's staff i
thought probably best that i do so so
the 41 000 i think it is you refer to
council of beer that's making provision
for staffing increase you're not giving
it to senior staff at this stage you'll
recall all councils will recall you had
a debate last september i think it was
in terms of the pay policy that wasn't
approved at that time but what was made
very clear by this council was that that
should be done through the budget
setting process that that was the
appropriate time of year to be looking
at these things so what's in the budget
is the potential for that increase
rather than the actual and a further
report will come back here in due course
where you'll have your chance to
determine whether you actually want to
spend that or not but clearly if the
provision wasn't made in the budget at
this stage then you'd be constantly
trying to catch your tail accordingly so
following the advice from full council
it's been built into the budget but i
suspect that will be march possibly
april where you will actually be asked
to consider that issue having rejected
it back in last september so just to
clarify on that one
thank you mr chair don't just come back
on that point thank you that does
clarify the point but it doesn't alter
the fact
that 41 000 pounds if we uh would be put
in the budget now and we could then
spend it in april so i mean the
likelihood is um don't put it in then we
can't spend it in april
thank you
uh yes um regarding the um the quarter
to out turn
which is
320 000 that is correct as i say that's
obviously a
a good position
and that is correct
quarter three is due soon and obviously
we can report on that
um
the 500 000 uh is in well the 200 r
baber element of the refurbished cost is
also in the budget
so that has been accounted for
um obviously that hasn't
gone through those at scrutiny today
um i i just realized i didn't answer
part of
counselor hinton's first point of his
question because it was right at the top
um
about spending and the budget and
whether a cautious approach the big
problem is and we're seeing it here and
it brings what reminded me was the 320
000 where we are
we're quite good as a council we can
actually our cost base is very good we
know what our costs are
the problem with the way that said
central government doll out money we
have to wait the 16th of december before
we know what the settlement is before we
can go forward and even then it's not
accurate because we then get other
grants money comes in and each year we
find that we do actually
receive more money coming in which we
can't account for because we don't know
it exists
so it's so
we we can take a a a more
relaxed latched approach and say okay
well we sort of know that's going to
come in
what then happens
and this is why you've got a projection
of 200
202.3 million in your medium-term
financial statutory at year
25-26
that's not really accurate because we
know we'll have more money coming in but
we have to take out new homes bonus
because that's coming out we've had to
say that will be replaced by something
and that will mean that we will be in a
neutral or in a surplus position
but with what we've got on the table and
how we're working the budget we cannot
we cannot do that so we have to take
that is the cautious approach
and i think sorry that was part of what
your question was one half we're good at
one side because we can we know what our
costs are going to be
the other side of the income side we
don't know because we're not we're not
like a business we can't have a
projection of saying oh you know where
our sales targets this we've hit our
sales target the income's coming in it's
not like that because we have to rely on
the central government giving us those
grant monies
so sorry i hadn't didn't answer that
point and i just hope that clears it up
thank you chair and thank you very much
for your report um as because other
people be listening to this i'm really
pleased about the 200 000 for the
communities
which is set up could you give us a
brief description of what sort of things
that would cover thank you
yeah i mean currently the communities
grant we we fund
about 55 000 to the citizens advice
bureau we fund 23 000 to things like the
key theater other organizations um
we also fund as well and we they can
beat for that money it's part of what we
as a district council can help with
those communities um and the other the
other thing is that where we've been
quite good
is uh we can see corn so basically we
can help organizations
then put together beats and this has
been key with people like saint peter's
um where they can we we've helped them
uh with a grant they put that grant in
they then go to their the like the
lottery fund or uh if you take other
organizations they go to the arts
council and that sort of initial money
that we put in they can then turn it
into millions of pounds but it's us c
calling that for the benefit of our
residents
and that's where it can help
thank you mr chairman just to come back
to councillor barrack first of all on
his answer about uh
cautious spending etc
we're spending everything that we've
budgeted for
what he's saying is that we're getting
more money in because we don't know it's
coming well he's suggesting that we
should go out and spend money in the
hope that it's going to come or not
going to come
and if that's the case is that why we're
sitting on the two percent pay award for
21.22 to staff because it's not being
paid yet
and that's in
page 26 of the report
well the staff one is a national
negotiation in our budget we have put in
two percent
currently the offer on the table is 1.75
this it's from april last year so we're
10 months in and it hasn't been paid
that's correct isn't it yes
um actually what what we probably should
be doing to our staff rather than is
sort of paying them
we could do that if we want the 1.75 or
the 2 we've budgeted for but they're
national negotiations so it's a little
bit out of our control
just to add to that exactly as councilor
barrett says that so that's for the
current year so back dated uh to the
first of april there's two percent
provision within the budget the current
offer on the table is 1.75
but that the point is it's an offer and
it hasn't been accepted and in fact it's
been subject to uh strike ballot by two
of the unions one of us one of the
ballots has voted not to strike the
other union has voted to strike
although we're yet to see what dates
that that may may take place
so it's up in the air still at the
moment but clearly once it's finally
agreed then it will be paid and it will
be backdated to last april
um thank you chair um yes following on
from that that topic i was going to ask
a couple of questions about this so it
seems a good point to come in
we've made provision for two percent
but obviously those negotiators are not
going very well and it sounds like the
unions and the uh staff you know they
might not settle on on two percent
so could we be facing a um
a wage bill that goes higher than two
percent um i know we've
heard that we've got some surplus in the
um budget so we would have the money to
pay for that that extra funding on on
staff wages
um i actually was going to make a
a request to ask a question if it would
be possible
to
advance pay to staff
back dated to last april because they
will get 1.75 we know that why don't we
give it to them now when the cost of
living is rising and they
they
undoubtedly could do with it like
everyone else they're seeing um all
their costs going up so there isn't any
any risk really to the council in
advancing that 1.75
on the basis that they're going to get
that or higher than that in due course
um and allow them they've waited 10
months for their pay rise um very soon
they'll be in
negotiations for next year's pay round
um so i i feel that we should be
considering that but i'd like to know
what what um
the thoughts are on where the
where the settlement will go and
whether we are looking at a higher
higher than two percent settlement
just about to look at it looking to me
now to answer these ones um
thank you yes so in in reverse order i
suppose so in terms of the 1.75 i would
absolutely love to do that i totally
agree
from a purely logical perspective it
seems a nonsense to think that it's
going to be less than that that's the
offer that's on the table therefore why
shouldn't we be able to pay it to staff
now we're being advised to the lga not
to do that
i know the county council is exploring
whether to ignore that advice
there is also another complicating
factor which would have to play into
this as well which is national insurance
will increase from the first of april so
if it is paid after the first of april
that will be caught by that national
insurance increase even though it's
relevant for the previous year so there
are some tax implications to this
as well and that may create some risk
but i'm more than happy to take away to
further explore it because yes my
preference would be to pay it well would
have been to have paid it already
frankly uh let alone to wait further in
terms of two percent for next year who
knows i think it'd be very difficult to
get crystal ball out on that front
certainly inflation is a lot higher than
two percent
i think normally the time that's looked
at in terms of when is it what time of
year is used as a ready reckoner there's
around about september time i think it
will be reasonable to assume that
inflation will be more than two percent
at inflation time sorry at september
time having said that um that isn't
normally although it's seen as an
inflation increase very rarely as it
actually matched inflation in terms of
the amount that's actually being paid
and you can look back over a number of
years including the years where it was
zero uh when clearly that wasn't where
inflation was at um traditionally and
that's an exaggeration on my part but
year and year the unions have asked for
something in the region of 10 percent
that's usually because they tried to
catch up from where it's been frozen in
the past
and it's usually been paid at near
enough somewhere between one and two
percent so budget provision has been
made for two percent
you could guess any figure um i think
two percent is a reasonable assessment
and catherine steele as section 151
officer may have want to comment on this
further but clearly if it's ultimately
settled at a higher amount and we may
well be having this conversation this
time next year bearing about how long um
this current round has taken to
negotiate um if it's ultimately settled
at a higher level then we'll have to
find the money to pay accordingly
i don't know whether catherine wants to
add
no i think i think the chief executive
covered it quite adequately you know if
that is the settlement then we will have
to find the money from somewhere to
obviously reach a balanced budget for
the for the year after so it will be one
of the factors that would be taken into
account in setting the next year's
budget
yeah um
it's a question first question is as a
result of what simon barrett has said
actually
because he said that he's introducing a
bit more risk to our budget
um and a more entrepreneurial approach i
think is what he said
referred to a 420 402 000 surplus i
think
um with a zip and that's with a zero um
council tax increase which was the
original proposal put to oh and s
um then he goes on to say but two
percent gives us an extra 120 000
so that's a good position to be in
so really it's a question for him
what is it is it a more risky
entrepreneurial approach or is it
actually more cautious and less risky
i think you have to look behind the
figures
because um
in previous years
we had
um
accounts where we had a naked at this
point we would
well not this point because we always
managed to get it right but up until the
point this was coming forward there was
a negative position on the budget
and uh as councillor arthur would know
his he's been in the cabinet now for a
couple of years he would know that was
the position so
last year and the year before i think
you were looking at these figures in
september october and you were seeing
negative figures on that which you
obviously can't set a budget with a
negative figure
can you
i'm asking well i'm telling you because
you can't you know that
so um
so basically what we are is in a
position
where we have a surplus
which is not at the expense of cutting
which is what you've done in the past
you cut services
and you've cut things so we're not
cutting services we're actually
increasing
grants to our communities we're keeping
things very much in place
we've got quite a lot of spending or
capital programs which has not been
affected as well so
i would say
yes it is
a fairly good
ultra
referred to the figures um could he just
tell us um
what the 4.3
rise in our council tax base
is worth
is
about 120
000
i'll tell him then it's 250 000. 251 i
think isn't it yeah but it's spitting
one
so what so could you tell me the
relevance of that
what's the relevance of it within the
budget because that actually can't be
changed right um it was a question from
there i don't have to justify why i want
to ask a question so but thank you
thank you for coming back
the reason
um to ask a question is to do with your
comment with regard to entrepreneurial
approach and risk and to do with um a
more cautious more proven approach
towards the budget
and of course the position that we're in
unusually this year
is that we're in a position where we've
got a 4.3
increase in our council tax base which
has actually given us a lot of
flexibility that's not an
entrepreneurial approach that's a bit of
good fortune
partly because we've got more houses
being built as simple as that
it's not as simple as that actually
because council tax base is not simply
on the number of houses it's a number of
band d equivalents
okay
cross chamber stuff councillor lindsay
thank you chair um yeah could i ask
about how much would the
original
parking
charging for parking proposals
would have raised
thanks
i i have not i don't know it's before my
time
um
what what would it raise
not a lot
sorry
185
from my colleague
yeah thanks
okay
councillor hinton
thank you chairman um
just uh
sticking for a moment uh on staff costs
uh we're talking about an additional
staff cost of 155 000 for new roles are
included in the base
so that means
an increase in their in the head count
which presumably fits in with the review
remodeling and reinvent which means we
need some extra staff to to actually
implement it uh is that correct
and also
on supplies and services there is a
figure of 93 000 for additional cost of
professional and consultancy fees for
asset and investments well as cifco is
effectively frozen now because the
government has said that we can't
get involved in those sorts of things
anymore
in terms of increase and we can't borrow
from the
public works loan board
what's the 93 000 for it seems like an
awful lot of money
for consultants for something uh in
terms of investment
and also uh
the contracts that mentioned by council
barrett in terms of
increasing our staff costs they're
actually saving us 852 000 according to
uh
according to these figures because it's
a reduction on the contract being
brought in house is that a net figure or
is that a growth figure
there's a net figure which is about 200
i think
which is the difference between there is
there is a saving overall no the savings
sorry it's 19 000 i think a net is it
19 000. yeah 19 000 is the net
savings for bringing the service back in
house
um
but clearly uh the the the main saving
is obviously when we've taken those
people back into our employment as
opposed to id verdi and then there was
other on costs as well
because of the contract which is about
860
000 something and then there's obviously
we've got capital expenditure as well
which we've had to put in
um on the cifco and the others i'm sorry
that's not part of my domain um
i
can't answer those questions on the 93
000 extra
it's in the budget but it's obviously
an area which is
someone else needs to answer because
it's not my area
yes thank you chair we've just sort of
had a look at the the detailed workings
and there's some money in there for
condition surveys for some of our own
properties so this is where you know
they are properties that we own that we
need to obviously get some work done on
them and sometimes we need consultants
fees so i think this does relate to
those condition surveys happening
you've got an entry here
of 55 000 built into the budget for
business rates on a car park in sudbury
could you please clarify and explain
thank you
well that's the business rates for car
parks
sorry
it's on the noise car park is the
business car park it's the rates that we
pay
so why are we paying the rates for a
business
because
roy's own the car park
and we provide the car park
as part of that as opposed to roy's
providing it's part of the deal that was
originally set up some time ago
to a retailer in the center of sudbury
most businesses pay their own rates not
at all the the benefit is the people of
sudbury that they can use that car park
if roy's wanted to they could just
insist that it was only for their
customer use but it's now for everyone
in baby to take advantage of it so
that's what it is so i think it's quite
a good deal from our point of view to
have that level of ground available
we we pay it's not ours it's their car
park
they allow us to use that for the
benefit of the people of sudbury and not
just sudbury of course the whole area
thank you
councillor beer thank you
thank you mr chairman um i've got
another question and that was to do with
the corks lane
car park
i understand that we've spent today
nearly five hundred thousand pounds or
perhaps even more on security there i i
mean what a waste of money mr chairman
why whoever allowed a situation like
that develop i don't know but can i can
i um
asked whether
this
will be reflected in the price or
is it still as
you know when we first looked at this
are we going to be at a loss at the end
of this of this 500 thousand pounds that
the council tax power has paid for here
thank you
thank you
is it a budget related question or is it
just uh
yes
the the costs that we've been incurring
in cork lane have been
not really down to our
anything that we can do we've had issues
apart from kovid but we've had issues
with one of the areas around in
determining the lease and planning
wouldn't go ahead until we've got that
issue sorted out so
we've had to maintain the building
if we didn't do that then it wouldn't be
worth what it is now
yes it has cost us approximately fifty
thousand a year and we'll continue to do
so until we actually get the building
going which we hope to do
in the early
spring so april may time
we've got
tenders out or tenders are in and we'll
be selecting the
the people the firm that will be doing
the work in the near future hopefully in
the early may sorry early march
so the work will get will
take place
i would hope that the whole project
whilst it being
marginal will provide a sufficient
income to cover those costs as well
thank you council buzzfeed
councillor arthi
wonder if we could give councillor
barrett and his colleague another crack
at the um the question regarding how
much income would be
generated in a year from the revised
parking charges
i'm not answering it
and
i if maybe i offer some clarity over
this
counselor arty if you remember the
cabinet paper that
sorry yeah sorry the cabinet paper we
approved um
uh back in february last year uh there
were some numbers in there and the
income uh there was a range i think was
between 100 110 120 000 those are the
sorts of numbers we were looking at
for the option that we had preferred out
of the three options that were presented
to us
111 i think is the answer
i didn't ask the question somebody else
asked the question and you didn't give
the proper answer
can we just
keep away from this cross crossed
count council
council beer
thank you mr chairman let's just uh
flash something across my mind could you
tell us um i don't know if it's within
your
brief um counselor barrett
how much additional money would we make
if we uh charge for the car parked
because we keep hearing how much we're
losing but how much we would get if we
charge for the car park in lebanon
thank
you well i have no idea
because well
i don't i don't know why we're getting
into car parking
but um
it seems that some people seem it's very
important and they will know they
already know the answers people they ask
them so it's just obviously just trying
to embarrass us and uh to make sure that
we sort of stand here and look silly
about car parking charges rather than
them looking silly about parking charges
which is you know uh
rather a daft position to be in
okay well i won't mention parking
charges yet
the cctv costs in hadley and sudbury is
that an ongoing cost to us and will we
get a report at all to show that the
investment is paying off
yeah um the there's an ongoing cost of
the cctv and there's also about 12 000
pounds from hadley and
10 000 from the parish council sorry the
town councils of hadley and sudbury
who also contribute to that running cost
as well
will there be a report to show
will there be a report
to show that the show that the
investment is actually making any
benefit
and that would normally come in the
police reports that the parish councils
get
and obviously i dare say we could then
tap into that to be able to report back
to see whether it has been effective
that would seem to be a logical way of
dealing with it
sorry i'm just gonna say could i just
sorry
i oh just going to try and assist on
that question so
members will be aware that on an annual
basis your ovule scrutiny committee is
obliged to hold a meeting specifically
looking at community safety i would
suggest that that's added on as one of
the discussion points when scrutiny next
looks at the community safety issues
clearly when it comes to return on
investment in relation to cctv that's
not something that is quantifiable in
terms of exactly how much cost saving
for example but there is obviously
qualitative benefit in terms of
reduction in crime and such like but i
would suggest that's sensibly passed to
the scrutiny committee without trying to
create work for council mclaren but i
would suggest that that's the place that
that can be followed up uh in due course
ansel parker and this will be the last
question
because we're moving into debate here
and i feel that
they're not absolute out and out
questions
um okay well uh if i can uh chairman
thank you very much i will return to car
parking if i can counsel about and it's
not the case of trying to make anybody
look silly at all but actually and
without sort of prejudging actually what
counselor lindsay was going to ask i
think it is a reasonable question it's a
fair enough question it occurs to me
that
if you're proposing a two percent rise
in in council tax and that's going to
generate approximately 120 000 pounds
and the parking charges would have
generated something similar
then
we're imposing
that rise on everybody within the
district i suspect that was where
council lindsay was was was going with
that so my question to you is
is it fair is it equitable that people
who don't use the car parks should pay
for the car parks
um i i think when you look in the round
so
the car parking charges um which should
be introduced would be about a pound an
hour
pound an hour
so you've got majority of your residents
within a 10-mile radius of hadley in
sudbury the majority
using those car parks so you think it's
better for them to pay a pound an hour
rather than 29
per month
because that's that's what you're saying
so you think it's better for the
residents of baber
to pay
one pound per hour for car parking
charges which they probably use once or
twice a week or 29 p
a month
you do
yeah just just very quickly um and
the question isn't whether i think it is
i'm asking you councillor barrett as
cabinet member for finance whether you
think it is fair and equitable that was
the question to you you've replied to it
with a question with due respect i think
it's perfectly fair for the majority of
residents of baby district council to
enjoy three three hours or three
hours parking free
which benefits our towns keeps them
commercially viable
and gives us a real usp over other
centers you've only got to look at other
towns where you know our rate of shock
closure is is high at ten percent but
that's really quite low you've only got
to walk around colchester coast
culture borough council if you look on
their website they've got a major
funding gap because they rely so heavily
on car parking as part of their normal
income stream we haven't got that
problem because we haven't relied on car
parking as part of our income stream
other district councils have got exactly
the same problem
what we've been trying to do is actually
make sure that our towns are viable and
we want to keep them viable and as a
small market town which we have we don't
have large centres where you have big
drawers you know we're not a berry
slimmers we're not at cambridge we're a
market town and that market town relies
on having some sort of usp what is that
usp i think it's the fact we offer three
hours free parking and that just really
does draw people in you've only got to
look around
um i've heard the things saying well if
you had a stronger offer the the town
would stand its own two feet but don't
dispute it it would but how do you get a
stronger offer when you're competing and
you look at the what's happening with
multiple shots all over the place
they're closing what's happening sudbury
and hadley has got a really good offer
from its independent traders
why are they coming there
because they feel that there is a some
sort of usp of people wanting to shop in
submarine hadley and we can say we've we
offer three hours free that's part of
our deal to help you the retailer in in
our towns
why we could say all right we'll bring
this parking charge in
so then we go looking for government
grants to help the high street
it doesn't seem to be any sense
so
i think as a council
i have absolutely no problem about
putting up two percent 29 p per month
or one pound an hour doesn't seem to
make any sense whatsoever
i've drawn the what's it to the
questions therefore
we would like to go into debate
um councillors will be uh
only be allowed uh to speak for three
minutes and
and we will be timed and once only thank
you
who would like to start the debate
council goals
yes
um well you know risk of being boring i
do want to bring up car parking again
and i do want to stand up for the
residents on the shortly peninsula and
you wouldn't expect me to do anything
else would you
um i've had
probably
three or four relatively aggressive
comments sent my way in local parish
council meetings
saying precisely what councillor parker
has said why should we be paying for the
people of hadley and sudbury to park
so i simply throw that into the debate
and i personally don't think it's
equitable and fair that people pay 29
pence everybody pays 29 pence a month
even our residents down at shotley and
in my ward
because they're not using the car park
councilor barrett it's the people who
are using the car park
who it would be equitable and fair if
they paid to use the car park
thank you
house of beer
thank you mr chairman
um
right
um
[Music]
why we can't get back to our nil
um or zero
rate that we decided on earlier on in
the year
is beyond me particularly as it's
already been highlighted that we have
three hundred and twenty thousand pound
surplus
um and that could be more before we get
to the first of
april
um
we have
we should not be spending money 250 000
pounds to
refurbish the officers
we should not be putting this money in
for the senior officers and i would just
like to point out that i understand they
work very hard they do a good job and
what have you but we just cannot afford
to keep paying this
at the end of the day it comes back
to
the our residents the hard work and
families the small businesses
and and the pensioners you know these
are the people that have got to pay
these council tax increases they've got
to pay for more food price has gone up
mortgages have gone up the
fuel
it's all a burden to them they are
struggling
and they who keep saying it's 29 pence
and i accept that we're not talking
about carl park and charges
that's been decided
this side of the chambers has always
been against car parking charges so i
don't have a problem with that but
certainly
from the point of view of increasing
council tax even by this amount
which isn't small to the average person
out there we can all look at ourselves
and some of us
maybe find it
struggling i know people who really
think this is the
last store
we've had bad weather at the weekend
they've had damages in their gardens and
promise of premises
their insurance companies the excesses
on them is more than perhaps what it
costs to get it done they've got to find
more money for that sort of in
you really need to stand back and look
and say we don't need it this year
uh we've got this surplus uh hopefully
things will be um we'll have a bit more
surplus money
we expect other people to
[Music]
take a hold because even with the
officers they're going to get inflation
increases
they will be getting that so it's not as
though they're not not being rewarded
they are
and
we need we need to make sure that at the
end of the day we're taking on board the
public because at this moment we're
ignoring them
totally ignoring them we're just putting
up all the charges and
some of us here might be able to afford
it but a lot of them can't thank you mr
chairman
um i don't always but i actually agree
with simon uh councillor barrett um
i think the reason sudbury i i don't
know about hadley to be fair because i
rarely go there if i'm honest but i know
sudbury
a lot of people come into suffering for
the free partner for the shops and the
money the revenue that's generated which
probably some of it comes back here to
baber
wouldn't the shops will be empty
everywhere in the country struggling
i agree
and i remember councillor gold gold
saying never been to sudbury i
understand that
but sudbury is probably
the biggest provider of council tax
and other things where the money comes
into baby so for me
i don't even park in the car parks but
i think it's great and i think it should
stay like that in other places give it
up
you should have fought for it when you
lost it sorry
um yes one of the things that i think it
might be appropriate to mention at this
point is we keep coming back to the car
parking
and um one of the
um
from the feedback responses we had
etcetera and all the analysis was done
last year
the
occupancy rate is extremely low in the
areas you're talking about and
particularly in pin mill
and holbrook
so i'd like my friend to be have these
places are not subsidizing sudbury and
hadley in fact quite the opposite in
that the occupancy rate is so low
anything considered belief below 50
percent
some of these car parks should be
considered for alternative uses
now we wouldn't want to see pin mill car
park and holbrook
so rest assured that they're not
subsidizing sudbury in
over the hadley
sorry
thank you chair i i would hate anybody
to be under the illusion that we've got
a car park in holbrook sorry councillor
dawson
but we would welcome one at any time
thank you
thank you um
so in a way go back to an earlier point
that was made staff uh the staff unions
their open-ended claims for the wage
increase puts us in a slightly awkward
position doesn't it because it hasn't
been settled it may go higher than two
percent so i do think that the
uh headroom that has been built into the
budget is is going to be necessary
um
because we we don't really know how much
that's going to cost us in the end
um
so
that that does push us towards towards
making this uh this increase in in the
budget and i support it
um
i wasn't going to mention parking the
topic of parking the toxic
subjects but
as it's it's come up and we can't seem
to break our unhealthy addiction to this
this topic
i will just say
the degree of scrutiny that some
councils are showing to this and the the
sort of the unwillingness to let go um
is baffling
um holding on to that possible
increase of our income by up to 200 000
perhaps
when
when some members have been happy to to
spend
250 000 on an office refit
can you explain that to me anyone
perhaps later on
simply put
council offices a requirement
the council
officers need to go somewhere
so and they do need refitting every so
often whereas car parking is not a
statutory service
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
i'll come on to uh car parking in just a
moment if i may
but i agree with i agree with what
counselor beer has said about the the
net cost that's being piled onto our
residence at the moment a little bit
here a little bit there it might only be
29 p.m months counselor barrett um or
whatever the figure is divided down to a
month but by the time the the
county councils
put theirs up the police precepts have
gone up the energy bills have gone up
the mortgage rates have gone up
everything's gone up but salaries have
stayed relatively flat
then and food's gone up in price um
then there's a problem for our residents
and if we can ease that burden even by
29 p a month
then that's something we should be doing
we should not be raising money just for
the sake of it especially when on page
24 of the report it talks about the
council's 22-23 gross expenditure that
goes on bringing in fundraising from
business rates council tax and
government grants shows a net surplus of
five hundred and seventy twenty seven
thousand for the 22 23 budget
page 24 of the written report
so if we've got a surplus of 500 000 we
had a 400 000 surplus from last year
even if they get a
a dirty great big increase
it's not going to eat up into that
because we're only talking about 198 000
for the two percent over two years
so that's that's
sort of shot that one down when it comes
to equity equitable
paying of car parks
if the council is going to spend 302 000
on car parks next year plus 55 000 for
the business rates on the
look in the figures council about no
good shaking your head at me that's
where i got them from in here
um why is it that they thought that two
pound a year lease on the car park in
east berghaut was too much and gave it
up
so that the parish council had to take
it up
and when it could when you're talking
about occupancy of car parks at holbrook
and shotley and everything else did
anybody read the report the other day
which said that the tourism spend and
the the income from tourism for
mid-suffolk ipswich and
baber was way down on what east suffolk
had done
why
because we're not giving them the
facilities in the right places
i can criticize the county council here
but three years it's taken them to take
to replace a tourist
facility in across the river store
the store the the so-called
star stall
scone schoons um
whatever you like to call it
the bridges at fenbridge has been
removed now it took two and a half years
to get it removed they then took up all
the trackway away
so that they can't put the new one down
and they put them until they put the
trackway back again and the cost of it
is going up and up and up
and so it's taking away something that
tourists can use so we're talking about
adding to the tourists spend and yet
we're not giving them anything and so
here we are talking about taking the
money off our local people when their
income sources of income are dropping
away thank you councillor hinton your
time is up
councillor jameson
thank you jeff
um
i find myself agreeing with councillor
beer and council hinton
um
i don't think we should be putting up
council tax this year we didn't need to
and um
as has been said already before the
burden he's been put on everyone in this
district
and i believe the reason
going back to the partying again the
reason we are chosen to put the burden
on everyone across the district rather
than
just putting the parking charges up is
purely political councillor barrow and
council dawson are looking into the
election next year and they're trying to
please residents of hadley and sudbury
is
i'd also like to come back to
[Music]
change the subjects like come back to
the climate change i'm not asking
council about to give me an open check
on climate change
i'm just asking him to make sure
he treats climate change and
biodiversity the same as he does all
other areas of spending and not put a
caviar into it as i said earlier he
doesn't put caviar into other areas so
why put caviar into
climate change
yes i know it will say we do we did hvo
and we've done pv and all
the other initiatives we put in place
and that's that's that is really good
it's brilliant we've done that but until
climate change biodiversity at front and
center of every decision that we make
and every um
initiative we put in place at the
council is the main thing
then
we're just tinkering around the edges
and only when we
think about these things before we make
a decision whether it be the budget or
anything else only then can we make a
difference
um and if councilman can stop being the
kinsey and
pouring over his budget books when it
comes to climate change
then perhaps it may make a difference
but thanks a lot
thank you mr chairman
you know as responsible councillors we
have to think not just for the
budget that we're deciding for 22 23 but
also beyond that into other years and we
have got a lot of
uh expense coming
towards us in following years for
example we've got the changes to our
refuse collection with the brown bean
collection
the food waste yes the government have
said they'll give us some monies towards
it but i bet you they don't give us all
towards it so we have to think ahead on
that one so we really need to be
responsible and think not just for this
budget that we're discussing here today
but for years to come to make sure that
when we do get to the following years to
set our budget that we haven't got to do
an enormous increase at least this way
we're evening that increase out so i
support this budget today because i
think it's the right way forward
thank you mr chairman
um first of all car parking since people
have mentioned or councillors mentioned
car parks in hadley where i represent
they don't
benefit
specifically residents of hadley because
we tend to walk to the high street what
they do benefit is the bizarre
businesses of hadley
they benefit
a vibrant high street and those
businesses
pay business rates so it's a win-win
situation
the people who benefit more generally
are from the surrounding villages
they're called visitors and that's what
hadley's usp is is to attract visitors
from the local surrounding areas in to
enjoy the facilities at the high street
give
this
as a conservative
i'm generally against unnecessary
tax rises during the debate excuse me
i'll cut that one
but
i joined in with our group discussions
on this uh budget increase
it's small it's i appreciate it is a
little bit extra
especially when hard-working families
are facing what um certainly i
talked about in that county last week
was the
rise in national insurance contributions
that they're affecting but this small
rise
is below the five pound we could have
gone to it is prudent and necessary and
i do support it thank you
thank you chair i've also got a throaty
problem
uh so you'll have to forgive me a bit
um
yeah the um
really just a couple of figures uh
um lee was quite right that um
the reason i asked about how much was
car parking raise
is because the amount's very similar
111 k or so
to the 120k that the 2
council tax increase
that all the residents of baba are being
asked to pay
the argument that
that oh a majority of people it doesn't
matter majority of people
uh want those car parks
um
another question that i could have asked
councillor barrett but i felt he he was
starting to feel a little
um
flustered perhaps so i didn't want to
ask him that but
the key question to ask is how many
households in baber
don't have access to a car or a van
and we got the answer in census
last census one in seven one in seven
households do not have access to a car
or a van
in baby district council
so we're asking those people
to subsidise people with cars
who fancy having a free parking spot
in
hadley or sudbury
now to me that is not fair that is not
equal and worst of all it's encouraging
subsidising driving
that money that hundred and eleven
hundred and twenty k could go towards if
we wanna support businesses and and i do
want to support especially independent
businesses in places like sudbury and
hadley and the way to do it is to help
support them to more directly not put up
not with a car parking free car parking
which helps drivers
and it helps people make the choice to
use their car
but put something into a shop a bus that
goes around
sudbury takes people from corner to
sudbury takes them to the shops the
businesses would like that
we know the more people that are
encouraged to walk
to the more places of pedestrianised
like advent sudbury the more
people go to shop because towns can
can't take all the shoppers they need
with cars they need lots of pedestrians
they're the ones that will spend more
more of them we can get into a town so
be more money for local economy more
money for our shops
so it's entirely the wrong remedy
this budget as as as my colleague
councillor jameson said
it it is entirely designed
um
to for a little election tick so we've
we've given
uh free car parking to residents of
hadley and sudbury is not looking at
equality and it's not looking at climate
change which is because it's encouraging
people to drive the walk cycles jameson
your time is up thank you
oh lindsay sorry sutton i do beg your
pardon counselor lindsey
council ward do you wish to come back
on your second
yeah thanks thanks chairman um gosh
there's been a lot said a lot said about
parking i'm not going to touch on that
subject um i've got a number of points
so firstly
i do actually concur with uh council
melody barrett on um why don't we pay
the 1.75 now let's ignore the lga do
what suffer county council proposing to
do there's no reason for not doing that
this this this council is far
far sighted we we recognize change is
inevitable
we have a continuous process of review
remodeling and reinventing and that is
working very well we see that all the
time
the refurbishment is only part of that
uh the 250k per council is a provision
we've had an estimate it's it's roughly
just over 200 000 pounds per council for
that one estimate we could probably get
further estimates to see
whether we can improve on that
but the point is we do need that uh
refurbishment and actually
we need to take into account the savings
the cost savings that will be will be
incurring by reducing our floor plate
consequently we'll have an overall
cost benefit of that refurbishment
in terms of climate change we're not
tinkering around the edges far from it
and i know councillor jameson you're
aware of all the things we've done uh
our hvo fleet twenty nine twenty five
point nine percent of our um
co2 emissions we've reduced that by
ninety percent
our leisure centers eighteen point nine
percent of our emissions the solar
panels we've installed solar panels on
our leisure centers reduced that by a
significant amount as well the solar car
ports the new water filtration system
the fact is we're making climate change
investments that make a real difference
a very substantial difference in our
carbon emissions
so now let's talk about the actual
council tax itself 120 000 pounds
it's not just
the
current year that we need to focus on
and not just for the uh the reasons that
council osborne next to me has has
stated the fact of the matter is that
120 000 pounds that the 2 rise is this
year but also has
an impact cumulative effect on
subsequent years so the effect of that
is worth a lot more than that 120 000
pounds and we must take that into
account our median term financial
challenge which is still there so we we
cannot um it would be imprudent if we
did not raise by that small two percent
now
council beer um
doesn't like that um
he doesn't like parking charges either
but that two percent as council barrett
said is 29 pence per month or three
pound 48.
per annum for our residence council beer
would have more credibility if he hadn't
voted for a 41 pounds per annum rise at
suffolk county council when he's the
county council the chairman on a point
of order
that's below and
there they've got 20 billion worth of
improvement i will continue with what
i'm saying here um
we must also remember
that uh council tax bands a to d are
going to receive 150 pound council tax
rebate to help them with that
so really um
we're not
imposing
thank you we're not imposing a burden on
our residents we're it's a modest rise
just to sum up i hope this wonderful
paper gets approved by council
i think it's fair it's concerned i love
council lindsay's selective the 1.7 one
one in seven people
don't have a car
most of those live in submarine hadley
because they certainly don't live in the
villages so i think that can you know
very very i mean i'm sorry you're
absolutely you know not on the button
there with the that
those people live in sudbury and hadley
so they don't need a car because they
don't have to very selective with the
truth and talk about electioneering
you're the greens we love the greens
because you're just a one-trick pony
anyway that's all i've got to say i put
it to you all thank you
debate this now debate is now complete
members
members is now the debate is now
complete
and
in accordance with the council procedure
rule 13.3
immediately after any vote is taken at a
budget decision meeting of the council
the names of councils who cast a vote
for the decision or against the decision
or whoever stained from voting shall be
recorded in a minutes of that meeting
i will now ask
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the recording vote
thank you chair um for clarity um the
vote that is taken tonight will be down
by modern.gov
and the difference will be that it will
still be published on the website
tomorrow but it will also be included in
the minutes
can i ask
recorded vote
it doesn't make any difference because
it's still recorded in both places
uh councillor the council actually
agreed to use electronic voting and
that's the method that we're going to be
using actually councillor you did vote
for that thank you
it's up to you it's up to you
i'm going to go for the electronic vote
so no no no it's the fact it's the fact
mr chairman that sadly i had to remove
myself so i didn't interrupt the
speakers too much for my coughing fit
am i still allowed to vote or not
because i've kept quiet in case
i was not allowed to comment during the
last
session
yes counsellor you are still allowed to
vote um it was for other part of the
questions and um you will be allowed to
vote
but could i also apologize to the
council for my coughing fit i do
apologize
so thank you chair that vote is now
going to be open if councillors could go
to that vote in showing in blue for
councillors to cast their vote thank you
lindsay i need to take your vote please
thank you
councillors are you able to
cool
councillor beer i think you've got
problems so can i take your vote please
[Music]
so chair the voting is seventeen four
and eight against we are now going to
show that on screen for everybody to see
but obviously we'll need to add in the
um two against and one four that we've
taken manually
so
that is carried yeah
that is carried members thank you
thank you
thank you members thank you for coming
back from the break
i'd now like to go on to item 9b
bc 31 2132
a housing revenue account
hra
2223 budget
and i would like to
invite councillor barrett to introduce
paper bc 2132 and to move the
recommendations in the report
thank you
hello fellow councillors
how great it is to be back with you
again
to introduce paper dc 2132
the housing revenue account
um i'd like to make the recommendations
uh or propose uh recommendations three
through to 37 and i would like to take
we could take these on block rather than
individually
obviously you can see what is being
proposed and this is the hra account
the main part of this account is the
increase in our council rents
this is based on cpi plus one per cent
which gives a total of 4.1 percent
uh that gives a increase of 3.72
or 3 pounds 72 per a week
for the social rents and 5 pounds 23 for
affordable rents
as you can see garage rents stay the
same sheltered housing services say the
same shelter housing utility charges are
kept at the same level
and the budgeted surplus for the hi is
511
and that is what is being projected as a
surplus of a year bearing in mind um
that we have suffered in quarter 2
a 499
deficit this is mainly due to the
building services costs of
repairing the council houses this is a
combination of
work or staff not being able to do it
access the houses which has actually
meant that we've had to use more
subcontractors in that period so that is
the deficit so bearing in mind that
we're going forward the budget has
increased
the
provision for
council for their housing repairs
by about five hundred thousand
so there's a sort of if you take the
surplus sorry to take the deficit and
then the repair there's about a million
pound movement in that between this year
and last year
i think the reason we've got the deficit
in this current quarter has probably
been we the budget has not
been accurate enough for what is
actually required
um so i think uh we're now hopefully
getting into this year's budget where
we'll have a more accurate figure for
those provisions
which is what we're looking to have
so
i propose this
if we could have a if i could have a
second to please
councillor
and uh questions i think
this will now move to the questions uh
council my counselors may ask as many
questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subjects under discussion
and must be a question
would like to start councillor hinton
mr chairman just as a point of order to
start off with i think to just to
correct what councilor barrett has said
there are not 37 recommendations it's
its recommendations 3.1 to 3.7 i think
he meant rather than 37 recommendations
sorry if i said that i obviously uh was
getting a bit excited of course it's 3.7
i i'm you know i missed the dot clearly
uh yeah i've got two questions actually
i think that rather than phil or the
cabinet member for finance they might
better be directed to the cabinet member
for housing or perhaps even the
uh housing assistant director but um
4.16
we say that um an increase of 21
properties has been assumed
um and that's obviously net after uh
taking into account uh an estimate of
about 12 for purchasing right to buy um
is is that not
rather a cautious
number given that
in the past years uh to date um for the
current year we've we've already um
acquired 94 through build or purchase
um and i would hope that our program for
the next financial year is going to be
just as ambitious so i think um
you know could could resume a greater
number than that 21.
also the second question is at 4.26
and that is concerning the right to buy
sales
um
our week and i know we've had an
extension in terms of the
time that we can use those or able to
use those right to buy sales receipts
but are we confident that we'll not have
to repay any right to buy receipts
thank you mr chen i'll take the right to
buy receipts the question first of all
if i may and then i'll go to our
assistant director to answer the the
next question uh the 2122 budget for
year was right to buy sales was 21.
the amount of right to buy receipts
received in the year was 2.42 million
and the amount of right to buy receipts
available to use is
2.09 million however now this may not
sound like good news but it is actually
better than it being underspent because
then we have to give the government back
the money and there's no way we want to
do that we want to provide
homes for people that need them excuse
me
um so the right to buy receipts used
towards new builds and purchases in the
year for 21.22 is 3.3
million so we've actually overspent on
that which as i said before is is really
good news um if i could ask the um
assistant director to answer the first
question please
thank you chair
in relation to the first question um can
we assume uh more houses will be built
than more than the 21
listed in the report that 21 is in
addition to the existing programme so
you can expect baber to deliver more
than 200
social housing or affordable rented new
homes over the next three years in
relation to the programme um so
yes you will be seeing more than 21
delivered in the next 12 months
thank you mr chairman i'll try not to
cough too much i'm sorry councillor
osborne
but i don't actually get your figures
you said that our receipts were 2.42
million
and that we could spend
2.09 million well if we can only keep
forty percent
that doesn't add up
sorry for forty percent
or
if i do it i've done it the other way
if you take sixty percent which is what
we have to give to government off of
2.42 million
and that is 1.45 million so that doesn't
add up to 2.09 million so i'm at a loss
with your figures unless
there is something that you haven't
quite explained thank you
thank you councillor mayberry i'll go to
our finance
151 officer if i may for that one i've
um provided the um
that's been provided to me so if you
could answer that one and in fact i
haven't got percentages i've just got
the actual amount
so apologies counsellors i haven't got
exactly that information to hand that i
might have provided in the past but um
there are different rules around the 40
the the 40
is the figure
that you can so if you've sold a
property and you've got some right to
buy receipts
then if you want to build or buy another
property then the income that you can
use from the right to buy receipt
the 40 percent
is what you
you can't use all of it to buy buy a
single property there's a limit on how
much so you have to put 60 of your own
resources
to um the money that you get in from the
right to buy receipts so that that's
where the 40 comes into it it limits the
amount of any one capital receipt that
you can use to purchase another so you
can't do a straight one one for one so
so that's where the 40
i'm not sure that i'm going to be able
to answer the question in more detail
this evening because i haven't got that
information in front of me i'd probably
need to go away and look at it and then
come back to cancel
thank you mr chairman if the 151 officer
could come back and that that would be
that would be useful thank you
that's a beer
thank you mr chairman um
i don't know whether council of barrett
can answer this but um i think
councillor jan osborne may be able to
help out on it
the
cancel
um
rent increase
i assume is across the board to all our
tenants
um am i right in assuming that 85
80 to 85 of them are in some sort of uh
benefit
um so they may not pay the full amount
of increase
which means that only about 15
of
our house and um cancer house tenants
um are actually paying the full council
rent could the the figures just be
confirmed to us thank you
um yeah it's uh of the um
council tenants we have 3437
[Music]
1682 which is 49
on housing benefit and they would have
that increase
paid for
um part of the
and there is a higher percentage but we
won't see that because uh people have
moved over to universal credit and the
universal credit will cover it but it
it's not something that we've actually
got the access to this particular time
so we can't tell but it is a fairly high
percentage
um but where people have moved over to
universal credit it's not for us because
it's not housing benefit universal
credit is paid by
the um
paid to the tenant and then paid to us
so we don't necessarily know exactly
what they've got where's housing
benefits paid directly to us
so that's i hope that answers that
question
chairman yes thank you a couple of
questions i need a bit of
clarification on please at back end of
416 page 84 it describes the
depreciation charge of just over a
quarter of a million and i'm a bit
mystified for that have i i'm used to
this in my business because machines get
worth less they get run down but
what's happened to our houses have bits
fallen off them or did we over value
them to start with um
a bit of an explanation please on that
one and i've got a second question
chairman um yeah i think you're as
baffled as i am about the fact that we
have to depreciate uh a house but it's
part of the uh in statute that we do
have to depreciate
our housing stock it seems slightly
ridiculous because as you've quite
rightly pointed out it's hardly a
depreciating asset
but that is the the regulations that we
are
unfortunately have it to have to take
into account
um it's slightly artificial really
because on the other hand we then have a
revaluation of the same properties going
the other way um so it's it's a little
bit of a
a very strange thing and if you look at
that also um which i find a bit i think
the valuation is only based on 38 of the
true market value which clearly is not
right so
it's there really as book entries it
doesn't really affect the day-to-day
workings of
of the hra but it it does seem a
slightly bizarre way of of having to
account for
quite a considerable asset
um
thank you um council about i was
slightly confused now i'm totally
confused um
i have worked out that our houses
if you multiply for three our houses in
total are worth about 750 million which
has been encouraging but
maybe they'll be depreciated and only
worth 700 million next week um yeah
maybe we can have a private chat and um
we can discuss that something
even more baffling um
[Music]
423 running into 4.24
the new build and acquisition program
has said identified development sites
for new homes that will deliver
68 affordable homes and 18 shared
ownership homes
for the end of march 26
and these houses are to be built
in chilton worsted lavenam
and boxford
now could you share with me please where
you are going to put these houses in
boxford and
how many you are thinking because um
nobody's told me and i am really
mystified
i don't need a house um council about i
already have one i could do the better
one but that's not in your grace to
offer surely
i never know um i i actually have no
idea where these approach so i would
defer that to uh
uh
gavin fisk
thank you chair um unfortunately i can't
give you any more detail than in the
report i'm happy to take that away
to give you more specifics these are
additional homes been identified by
the assets and investments team in terms
of
new build delivery
and possibly through section 106. i'll
take that away and come back to you
counselor hurry
um
is it not possible to get me an answer
before i vote on this um otherwise i may
even have to vote against it it's quite
a shock to come and you know i've known
about this for a week since the papers
um to find your planning
to build somewhere in my ward
and i don't know
yes please do
so i'm not going to give you the answer
you're looking for guests at home but i
am going to throw a question towards
gavin fisk and see whether i can elude
an answer in relation to it so i suspect
that these homes aren't homes that we
are building i suspect their homes that
we're buying where the developers built
or we'll be building them and some of
those will be one of six properties for
affordable housing and so we're
purchasing them to add them to our
council stock but i'm looking towards
gavin to see whether i'm getting a yeah
i'm getting a nod so
to provide you with some reassurance
counselor and these aren't extra ones
that you don't know about yet they'll be
they'll relate to things that have
already been granted planning permission
that you will will be aware of it's just
that the council will be acquiring some
of those to add to as council houses
from alluring to
a planning application that's not passed
and once again um
these probably aren't deliverable so i'm
i'm
really asking some certain questions
here
uh yeah some clarity councillor haran um
16 units sandhill
um still awaiting decision on on those
so it's on on the sand hill
well that is my point this in all
likelihood hopefully will not happen so
i'm not sure
why it's been put in the papers in case
it does that's not surely that's not
right and i can't be expected on to vote
on something that
i think cannot be delivered
thank you mr chairman i think
um
on regards to the planning application
obviously it's it's not within our remit
to discuss a live planning application
this certainly isn't the forum for doing
that
as the chief executive has explained
it's an application that if in the event
it gets approval there will be an
element of affordable housing and we
will look to bidding for that element of
affordable housing so in the event that
it gets that it does get approved and
i'm not saying that it will necessarily
i would think that i would like to think
that you would like there to be an
element of affordable housing in your
village to help those people that need
to be housed
but you know
as to voting for this paper i don't see
that it makes
any sort of connection to that at all
this is just a planning application that
there is a possibility if it gets
approval there is already an element on
a 106 agreement of a percentage of
affordable housing
i'm still uncomfortable i shall either
up today nor vote against it because i
think honestly it's a bad thing to do
okay
counselor hinton
thank you mr chairman well on that
particular point and when you consider
the annual monitoring report for they
came out in december
showed that there were 4
900
permissions granted
across baber
or 30 35 of those that's a little bit
more than 28 or whatever it is that
we're talking about here 68
affordable homes that's a little bit
more than that added to which of course
to say that
those
people would be glad to have those homes
in their in their ward
so that um
their residents can have them it's a bit
of a red herring as well because they go
into the gateway for choice uh yeah my
my question around that because i
thought that was a point that needed
elaborating
is that uh according to the chart on
page 83
weber's weekly rents
are about the highest in the country
is that why our retail prices are of our
homes for buying our so expensive
because it's just as expensive to have a
an affordable stroke social house
[Music]
hinton's question there i was going to
ask similar if we are already we already
seem to be substantially higher weekly
rents
than other neighbouring councils and
also across the country is it fair that
we should be raising
weekly rent for our residents
and a second question
while i'm here i understand we have a
retrofit program in place but i can't
see that mentioned in the budget
directly i wondered if someone could
point me to where i could find that
thanks
thank you for your question on the first
one regarding the level of rents
you've been making a point that you want
us to
go out and retrofit our properties and
make them energy efficient to do that we
need the rent coming in to enable us to
be to be able to do that so that's one
point i think you need to take into
consideration you can't have it both
ways and what was the what was the other
the retro fit in yeah that comes under
planned maintenance and um
i could stand up here and tell you what
we've spent on we've just spent
over um 77 000 on
springlands seven sorry seven hundred
thousand on springlands making them more
energy efficient we've done the same in
minden and cavendish there's more um
retrofitting coming forward so there is
definitely a program
coming forward on this but of course it
costs a lot of money so we've got to
balance it between as i've said on
numerous occasions of retrofitting our
properties and also looking at providing
homes and that's a decision that members
will have to make when we come to
approving the hra business account thank
you
i didn't get an answer on why our rents
were so high compared to everybody else
if it's because we are the only ones in
the country retrofitting our houses uh
how on earth are everybody is everybody
else sort of effectively getting away
with it and my the main purpose of the
question about those levels of rent is
is this likely to increase the number of
our tenants who either
fall into arrears or who have to rely on
benefits of various sorts to
survive
thank you chair just to come back to uh
councillor hinton's question in relation
to why vapor rents so high um there are
some key principles in relation to
setting social rents these were set out
by the government under social rent
policy um and uh in accord with those
ensure that every uh rented uh socially
rented property is based on a formula uh
and a formula in which the rent is
calculated uh that's the same for baber
and all local authorities just to give
you some more detail on that
those formula rents that are set for
which we
cannot uh cannot change or alter
are reflected around the condition
location of the property
local earnings and property size so 30
of a property's rent should be based on
relative property values 70 of the
property's rent should be based on local
earnings and a better factor to take
into account as well
mclaren sorry
thank you jeff uh yes i'm interested in
the 11.2
um which is about the 85 air source heat
pumps that were installed
can i just in the light of the previous
question by councillor jamison
um is that are they included in the
700 000
it was quoted
on the second point no the um 700 000
that i referred to for springlands was
removing cladding that they've got on
the wall
and re-insulating and then rendering
so my question then is
uh do we have a cost on those 85s
saw air source heat pumps that were
installed and my second question is are
we going to evaluate the benefit
to residents from those
pumps
because i think that would be very
helpful thank you joe thank you
thank you chair so in relation to the 85
air source heat pumps that that's
looking back in terms of work that's
taking place obviously we have a program
looking forward to install more of those
air source heat pumps on both our
general needs stock and our sheltered
housing
what i can tell you is that whenever we
look to install an airforce heat pump we
look at a variety of factors in terms of
whether or not that heating is
appropriate for the accommodation
and as such as part of that we will also
take and carry out additional retrofit
measures to improve the overall
makeup of of that home so in addition to
an s or heat pump that might come with
also external or internal wall
insulation as an example
where that requires also education is
education of the tenant to inform them
as to how the air source heat pump will
work
what they can expect in terms of running
costs and how to manage and get the best
use of it
any other questions
counselor maybe
chairman um
uh rumor has it to me
that some social housing
groups
um
are
considering what they're doing about
rent increases
because there is a question at the end
don't worry
um because
they have worked out that if they
increase their rents
they have to increase their um
their money that they put aside for
those people who can't actually pay
their rent
so i have a two-part question here one
is
are we actually doing that
because we pay into the shared revenues
partnership so is it going to come out
of that
and the other part of my question is
because utility
charges are going to be so much higher
next year
would we not have been better
increasing the utility charges for our
sheltered housing
rather than increasing the rates there's
two questions there thank you
thank you chair uh thank you councilman
in um relation to the first question um
i think it was in relation to the cost
of living and the impact on any higher
rent uh for tenants that may
find it difficult to pay
we already offer a comprehensive tenancy
support service um through
the staff that work for forbidden
mid-suffolk and part of their role is to
ensure
income maximisation and look and work
with individuals around budgeting
and access to to grants etc so we
wouldn't be looking to
increase our provision
in that regard
we're happy that we've got sufficient uh
coverage to to manage that but what we
are looking at as as an authority is
that cost of living uh crisis that
potentially could be looming in in the
months or years to come
and our roles and responsibilities and
our ability as a council to to
effectively uh support those in in
greatest need
an example of that would be for example
making best use of discretionary housing
payments um or homeless homelessness
prevention grants that we've received in
the last year in relation to the second
question the proposed um no increase to
heating and hot water charges that's
specifically to sheltered housing
tenants so only those where there are
communion to a community communal
facilities
and that's because of the collection
that we've already incurred in recent
years which means that we don't need to
increase this year the cost of those
heating and hot water charges because
we've got sufficient coverage in terms
of bills
questions
counselor maybe thank you going to come
back because i'm sorry gavin that you
didn't really answer my last question
because
my question to you was would it not be
better
to increase utility charges rather than
increase rents and i did say to
sheltered housing
and because in my opinion and i'm only a
lay person i don't live in the sheltered
accommodation but i do know lots of
people that do
that i'm sure that they would be happier
to actually pay a little more for the
for what will be increased utility
charges rather than um for rents
and so if you could answer the question
i would be happy a yes or no would be
fine thank you
thank you chair thank you councillor
mayberry um so in relation to sheltered
we talk about sheltered and older
personal accommodation it can take many
forms it can take accommodation where
there is communal living and there are
communal surface charges incurred it can
also be individuals that are of an age
living in sheltered accommodation but in
a uh in a bungalow so actually there is
no service charges that that need to be
accounted for
in relation to service charging we
cannot charge more than the cost of
those services
so therefore when collecting service
charges we're only collecting the costs
of the service
not a penny more so the principles of
the rent increase applies to to all
tenants
any other questions
then as you'll move into debate
uh and uh i'll just remind members that
uh that you'll be allowed to speak for
three minutes and once only
who would like to start a debate
council award
yeah thank you i don't really want to
say too much um i know we've had some
questions surrounding the
um
the proposed increase in in rents but i
think it's a it's a it's a modest
increase and it's um
takes into account uh cpi as it was uh
back in september last year so um cpi
now is is uh significantly more so um
and uh the point has already been
mentioned that um many of those tenants
are in receipt of uh housing benefit or
universal credit um so i i think this is
a sensible budget uh for our hra and and
i'd be very happy to support it i do
want to make one one comment on on the
paper before us uh actually and that is
um
the uh
the information that's been provided at
416 i think is excellent this year it's
a lot better than we've had in the past
years and it allows us to make
our decisions based on
a huge amount of more information which
i think is very helpful for us so i do
commend
gavin and his team for
providing that information i think it's
very useful so i i think it's um
excellent budget for our hr anything and
that's all i need to say thanks
speak on debate
would you like to
take your position on the second of that
to speak
yes
thank you
we have a very healthy hra which will
enable the council to deliver on
priorities identified by both our
residents
and members
four years ago we promised to deliver
214 new homes to add to our housing
stock we have actually already delivered
228
we are making our homes more energy
efficient to ensure that utilities are
kept to a minimum especially at this
particular time
as well as delivering on our carbon
reduction
this was identified by residents as one
of their priorities
however
this is good news but at the same time
we will continue to have challenges in
meeting these priorities and i am
pleased to second this report and the
recommendations within it thank you mr
chairman
uh no i just think we've it's had a good
debate um i think our tenants um
hopefully will benefit
from the increase in our capital
spending
i rather like to see that that is spent
to improve our housing stock
it's programmed
the delivery of it is difficult it has
proven to be difficult we've budgeted to
increase that to help get that done i
think it's very important that the
quality of our housing stock is uh is
actually kept at a high level um you
know it's we want to be a proud landlord
and offer the best we possibly can at
the best value and i think this is what
this budget does
council procedure rule 19.3 immediately
after any vote is taken at a budget
decision meeting of the council
the names of the councils who cast a
vote
for the decision or
against
the decision or who abstained from
voting shall be recorded in the minutes
of that meeting
i'll now ask corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the recorded vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors would like to
cast their vote thank you
would you like to cast your vote
thank you
yes please
so um
council we have 19 votes four three
against two abstentions we are now
displaying that on screen
we've got three not voted but we have
taken those into account manually and
michael holt has left the meeting so
thank you
thank you jen
so that's carried that is carried
members
i'd like to now go to item 9c
sorry
did everybody get that
uh i would like to invite councillor
haran
to introduce
paper pc 2123
f-33 and to move the recommendations in
this report thank you
councillor
thank you chairman oh i've just um the
red light just come on
it's a long report and i apologize for
that so it's quite a long intro but i'll
be as quick and concise as i can
i'm pleased to introduce this report
which we discussed at our meeting on the
24th of january
under the
treasury management code of practice and
the prudential code both published in 21
and the department for leveling up
investment guidance published in 2018
we are required to determine separate
capital and investment and treasury
management strategy statements
and prudential indicators annually
before the start of each financial year
there have been no significant changes
in format this year and it has been
updated to reflect the latest capital
expenditure
investment and borrowing and the latest
treasury management investment and
borrowing positions of the council
the strategies and indicators to be
approved are in the appendices to the
report and i will now give a new
overview of each of these
appendix a is the capital strand
strategy
this summarizes the capital expenditure
and financial requirements of the full
capital program for both general fund
and the housing revenue account the
details of which are in the budget
report
this also sets up capital expenditure
and capital investment decisions
and the associated risks and rewards
along with how risk is managed
for future financial sustainability
it includes potential indicators which
demonstrate that the council's
investment plans are affordable
prudent and sustainable and decisions
are made according to good practice
it shows that capital expenditure plan
for 2223
including carry forwards is 41.1 million
of which 22.9 million will be funded by
borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the prudential indicators
and the strategies shows that projected
borrowing will not exceed
these limits
appendix b that encompass the investment
strategy
this details those expenditure items in
the capital programme
that specifically relate to assets
bought and or owned by the council
purely or partially to generate a return
this includes schemes which have the
purpose of regeneration or development
of the local area
as well as
generating a return
in the context of this strategy
investments
means those non-treasury management
activities
the department for leveling up
investment guidance defines these as two
types of investments
the service provision
where the council's lend to buy
lend to or buy shares in organizations
that provide a service
or there's investments for yield
where the primary purpose is to generate
a return
such as the council owned company cifco
the strategy explains how each
investment contributes to the council's
priority
and its security liquidity liquidity and
risk
it shows the projected total investment
of the council in cifco
and the growth company and planned
expenditure on the council's property
held at least in part for investment
purposes
appendix c that's the treasury
management strategy for 2223
and this sets out the council's
borrowing requirement
and borrowing and treasury management
investment strategy
this also includes the list of approved
investment counterparties and the limits
there has been no significant change to
limit since last year
appendix d is the treasury management
indicators
which we use to measure and manage the
council's exposure
to treasury management risks appendixy
is the economic update and this interest
rate forecast
which is changing um
uh pretty fast at the moment the ongoing
impact on the uk from covert 19 together
with higher inflation
the likelihood of our higher investment
rates
and the cap country's trade position
post-brexit will be major influences
on the council's treasury management
strategy for this coming year
at the time of writing this report
the authority's treasury management
advisor arling close
was forecasting that the bank of england
bank rate will rise to half a percent
which already has
in the first quarter of 22 and remain at
this level at at least the final quarter
of 24
arlen close has since revised this
forecast and now expects the bank rate
to rise by to 1
by the middle of this coming year
appendix f
that's the current investment and debt
portfolio
and that shows the position that 30th
november last year 21
the borrowing for weber currently is
118.7 million
of which 94.7
is
from the public loans workboard at fixed
rates and 24 million
is short term
on the investment side weber has
21.6 million invested
including the ccla ubs schroeder
investec and funding circle
we have continued the policy of
withdrawing funds from the funding
circle as loans drop out
and we have not invested any new money
appendix g is a treasury management
policy statement this underpins the
strategy and sets out the council's
regard to the monitoring of risk and
performance
appendix eight appendix h is the minimum
revenue provision statement
which shows the basis on how we put
aside the resources to repay debt in
later years
and finally appendix eye shows the
institutions meeting the highest credit
ratings criteria
and appendix j is a just a glossary of
terms german
i think at this point i should thank the
staff and all the councillors who
sit on the a and s committee
i think
you know i'm chair of this committee and
we see all the figures coming out
and we check them and um
i have to say um the performance of this
committee is um
on the ball i think um
this is something it needs doing um i
passed no comment on what happens
nationally but i think locally um
everything is in order
i would like to um propose the
recommendation to set out in three point
one two three seven of the report
and would ask for a seconder
and
we have rebecca and catherine here as
well as myself so hopefully we can um
handle any questions that might arise
chairman
thank you very much thank you councillor
haran could i have a second please thank
you council arthi
would you like to reserve your right to
speak
thank you
all right
we'll now move to questions
counsellors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question
we'd like to start any questions
counselor beer
excellent report can we put the question
thank you
then i shall
go to debate
um
uh who we wish to ah the questions have
finished so uh you'll have three minutes
to speak and only the once
um
who would like to start the debate
council jameson
thank you sir
um part of the appendix say relates to
the environmental
social and governance issues
and partly to believe this is our
investments in fossil fuel companies
cabinet recently decided to just sit on
their hands and not to look at divesting
investments away from these fossil fuel
companies
because
we said fossil fuel companies are doing
a lot to try to
combat climate change we need to invest
in these companies if we're going to
make they're going to make a difference
this despite the fact that bp shell and
chevron increased their production
volumes over the last few years
and bp and shell who are the best of a
bad bunch
invest only about 2.6 of their capex in
clean energy
if we continue to make these investments
we're making investments that are a risk
and we should have taken the opportunity
to look or divest in away from these
and um that's it thank you
yes wish to come into debate
council award
yeah can i just quickly respond to that
um
some numbers here
you'll have heard we've got uh
11.1.2 million pounds invested in
externally managed
long-term investments pooled funds
since that we took out these investments
they generated a total return of 2.72
million at an average rate of return of
4.1
and we've used that to support service
provision
6 million pounds of that is invested
equally in three called funds managed by
schroeder's ubs investec
now we don't invest directly in any
stock fossil fuel or otherwise
and the principal fossil fuel holding is
14.54 percent of the schroders fund
that's held in bp shell and the italian
company eni
the other funds have minimal exposure to
this sector so in reality our total
indirect fossil fuel investment
is likely to be no more than a few
hundred thousand pounds not the millions
that um i think you're worried about
but and uh i will repeat this i said it
on more than one occasion must be said
that the current strength of the ftse
100 is due primarily to 10 stops
including shell and bp
they're not poor investments
and they are delivering for us
and yes
like it or not they are moving into
becoming energy companies and they're
not just fossil fuel companies we should
support that move
that they're undertaking
thank you chairman
councillor lindsay
thank you chair
um
yeah i just uh
just really to
uh make a point for members who maybe
weren't involved in this debate
um
but
the the officers told us
that there are alternative funds
available
we can switch from we don't have to have
schroders managing it we can have
another fund just because we don't
directly invest in it doesn't mean we
can't find cleaner funds than we have
um
and the quality of debate the cabinet
that i listened to i'm afraid was pretty
poor there was
a lot of talk a lot of the personal
opinions of council award and some of
the other cabinet members about how
important these companies were there was
no assessment there was no cost benefit
analysis it's quite easy we have ireland
close we have a paid manager it's quite
easy to ask and do a cost benefits what
if we switched all these
all these are
four different funds into
into funds that are actually filtered
uh for greener investments how much
would that cost and what are the likely
returns and it's very easy them to press
a few buttons on their
computers and and give us those figures
that wasn't done it was just on the
basis of well we think shell and bp are
great and they're going to invest in our
future with no evidence the evidence
we've just heard from councillor jameson
less than two percent
of their capex is put in renewables this
is a company that's supposedly our
future for renewables they should be
putting fifty percent in if they talk
about genuine
genuine desire to change their business
structure to change their module model
they should be stopping drilling at all
and putting all their money into
renewables that's not what they're doing
thank you so i shall be opposing
this element of the
are we
desire
for our green members to want to reduce
fossil fuels
but we've just come through the worst
pandemic the world has ever seen
and all those people who survived
who are alive today
are alive today thanks
to the development
of fossil fuel byproducts
ventilators
cannulas
the sacs holding blood
the beds they sit on
we're here surrounded by fossil fuel
derived
the computers we use
until such time
as other companies come that can match
the resources
and the
research
that these companies have have done in
the past and are doing now
then and only then can we say to them
switch the pumps off
i shall be supporting the paper thank
you
[Applause]
would you like to take your
position as uh to speak
okay thank you
um chair before we just go to um to sum
up by councillor haran if we are fast
approaching the guillotine could i have
a proposer and a seconder please to
extend the meeting to allow the
remaining business to be heard
[Music]
um
and can you just do a consensus vote
please all those in favor
say thank you that's carried carry on
yes chairman definitely um this debate
um
just rolls on doesn't it um and thank
you councillor melvisi for your
um hells of wisdom thank god you're on
this side of the um council chamber
i think um
no comment there
i think it should be said and i may ask
one of the officers of this i think the
um
investment in the fossil fuel that
causes all this
debate is probably not able to be split
away anyway as far as i'm concerned it's
part of a
rolled up package of funds and i'm not
too sure we can actually um pick that
single one out quickly
i think it has to wait until the whole
lot comes
for renewal and then maybe we will do
something then
um but can i
reassure those behind me whatever the
answer to that is i have not
um
lost track of this
we've handed the ball over to the
cabinet and i've already warned them in
the debate when i
was asked to talk um
i will hold your feet to the fire over
this and
you will be punished if you don't um
move on this you really will it's
becoming a huge election issue
um
things can be managed and in the debate
which councilor barrett supported by the
way at the time because he sat on the um
committee at that time i don't look to a
ghast dumb counselor about it um
you you actually supported this in your
brief
um
encounter with the um
audit and standards committee but that's
by the by but um
yeah we must not lose sight of this and
i've already um had a word with council
award and um as long as i'm chairman
which i hope will be for another year i
will continually hold his feet to the
fire we do need to move on this but it
must be
sensibly and um maybe katherine
norbrecker could just come in now and
confirm what i said previously as being
true or untrue because i think it would
be helpful to debate thank you
thank you chair thank you councillor
harren um yes what council harold was
saying is correct that we invest in a
fund and that fund then uh has a number
of shares and obviously some of those
could be with fossil fuel so we can't
pick and choose which elements of that
total fund so if we wish to divest from
a fossil fuel element we would need to
remove ourselves from the funding
totality that's the the investments that
we have got at the moment
you catherine
uh the debate has finished it
um thank you
i will now ask corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic voters
no you've already spoken cancer lindsey
we're in debate
we're in debate
okay clarification
yep it was just if we do
so
i i know that i appreciate we have to
sell we'd have to sell for example
shoulders we'd have to sell the whole
fund
but what is preventing us from doing
that
i'm sorry but
you've already spoken time now go to the
electronic vote
thank you uh jan
okay councillors that vote is now in
progress if you can cost your vote
please thank you
so chair the voting is 24
the recommendations and three against
four against sorry county councillor
lindsay's so that is carried thank you
thank you chairman this one's um a bit
shorter i'm pleased to say in a bit
easier
our current five-year external audit
contract was let let by public sector
audit appointments i'll call them the ps
double a
following a national procurement which
the council opted to join in 2016.
the current contract does include the
audit of our 2223 accounts and was led
to ernst young along with all the other
councils in suffolk
we now need to decide and let pswa know
by the 11th of march
if we again wish to join the national
procurement exercise to let a further
five-year contract
and this is a decision that only the
council can make
we discuss the three options ordered and
standards outlined in the report
along with our respective risks and
benefits which were to
opt in once again to the ps double a
option
make a stand-alone appointment
or set up a joint auditor panel with
local joint procurement arrangements
we are aware that there have been
national issues with the timely
completion of local authority audits in
the past couple of years
but we supported our section 151
officer's view
that this isn't due to the national
contract arrangements
and hence believe we should continue to
coordinate our efforts through these
arrangements with other councils to
tackle the challenges
the lga's view is also that the national
procurement
remains the best option for local
authorities
our recommendation to council is
therefore to continue to opt in to the
psa option
so i would like to propose the
recommendations are set out in three one
and three two of the report
and would ask for a second
thank you chairman
no it's all competing thank you
everybody
i now move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion
and must be a question
thank you mr chairman um just a quick
one um
one of the things that concerns me about
auditors is the
the rather sort of
dubious reputation that they've got for
themselves in various aspects during the
last few years and it is mentioned i
believe on page
158 of the report
but it doesn't say anything about what
is being done to actually make sure
that whoever is selected by the
the psaa
is actually going to comply with
some good standards
to
make sure that we don't get caught up in
any of the fracar that's come from some
of the other ordered
big companies et cetera that happened in
recent years i wonder if somebody could
comment on that please
yeah we
we do go through a selection process and
that's exactly what um is done for us
but catherine can answer in more detail
i'm sure
thank you chair thank you councillor
horan
there is a the national procurement
would be done by psaa and they obviously
set out a detailed specification as to
what they expect from the
firms that could bid for the contracts
that will be let
but there are other standards that
auditors have to comply with you know
there are various bodies that they have
to report to
and
they have to comply with with those
requirements so say there are various
routes um i would say that our current
external auditor ey
i'm not aware of they have necessarily
been caught up in any of the some of the
issues that you might have seen
nationally but it wouldn't necessarily
be in our control as to who our auditor
would be again through the national
procurement um because it said down to
the national firms as to who applies and
then who psaa might appoint to a
particular region so i think there are
controls in place but i equally know
there have been reports in the media and
i've seen them myself as well about some
of the audit firms so it's probably
impossible to give 100
assurances about that
thank you catherine
this gemini could just come back briefly
and say well out of the big four i think
they've all been involved in some sort
of shenanigans somewhere or other along
the line in in recent years
but uh
the
extension of the question would then be
does the psa
psaa have any connection to the fca
in terms of uh being able to
sanction these auditors if they do screw
up because after all it's us who
ultimately takes the rap for it
apologies i've missed the abbreviation
that you used
okay thank you um i don't believe that
psa have any powers to sanction the
auditors um i would need to look into
exactly what their their roles and remy
is but i don't think they can ultimately
sanction they can obviously not award
future contracts to them i don't think
they have the the powers to actually
sanction they talk to the audit firms
obviously if there are issues raised but
say i don't believe they have any uh
powers of sanction
i
don't know i'm afraid that's beyond
beyond my my remit sorry
councillor busby
israel can you tell me the reason why uh
babies scale fees 10 percent higher than
mid suffix
i'm afraid it's purely historic
um they have been higher in the past and
i think they've actually been higher
since prior to my involvement with baber
so
they tend to look at me year to year so
they look at the risk and they base it
on the previous year's figure so um
they have historically been higher and
they probably would continue to be
higher on the basis that the fees are
set each year
well can i just say i would have thought
it was time for us to talk to the the
auditors and say
you're in you're auditing the same
figures
with the same people why on earth is one
council paying more than another there
doesn't appear to be any reason for it
historic pricing isn't as good isn't a
good enough reason for us to keep paying
an extra four thousand pounds
the auditors themselves don't set the
fees the fees are set nationally by psaa
so it's not the auditors who are making
the difference
saying they are they are all done on a
similar basis nationwide they say it's
just a quirk of history that the two
councils have been different and are
likely to continue to be
are any more questions
question if if all these councils are
being the fees for the audits are being
set on the same basis
which presumably is a financial basis
and not a historic basis
because what happens if two councils
join up
like east suffolk have
how are they going to set that they'd
have to have some sort of criteria
surely those criteria or what should
apply and not just taking last year's
figure and adding a percentage to it
they do take a number of factors into
account and risk risk profile is one of
them and what the council is involved
with and what it's actually doing as as
an organization so they wouldn't have
just added together the two councils
that formed formed east or similarly
west they would look at what that new
council was as a whole and then come to
a
conclusion as to what they felt was a
reasonable fee figure for that
particular council so say it's based on
uh mostly a risk profile and say that
has been historically set and then they
look at revising that risk profile each
year to see has something changed within
that organization that would change the
fee figure
any more questions i should go to debate
debate
yeah thank you um
yeah
yeah stupid debate now yeah i'm just uh
remind everybody you're allowed to speak
for three minutes
uh it will be timed and once only
councillor barrow
i'm just going to debate the fact that
this is catherine's last
full
council
budget treasury
hra
presentation
and support to the likes of me who i
need lots of support as you well know
um
but uh just like to say thank you very
much catherine
it's
been a pleasure working with you on and
off i
had a little break in between the
electorate disapproved of me but then i
came back because they like me again
so
i on behalf of my fellow councillors um
i'm sure
we'd all like to say thank you very much
and enjoy your retirement when it comes
around
[Applause]
yeah i'd like to uh second what council
barrett's just said catherine gave me a
huge amount of support for the years
when i had the finance portfolio
she's been absolutely brilliant as a
section 151 officer we will miss her
but
she's got plenty to do to keep her
occupied in her retirement but just
quickly to focus back on on this
particular paper it's a no-brainer
really um the two options that have been
discounted uh have severe disadvantages
um the recommendation as stated is
really the way forward and uh can we
just get on and vote for it please i
think it's the best thing to do now
thanks catherine
thank you council award thank you
catherine and i'd just like to
concur with with the two council that
spoke to you uh there's a number of
councillors here that have known you a
great many years and i appreciate
exactly what you've done thank you
right
no more debate
is there anything you wish to add
okay
um so i'd now like to um
go to the corporate manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote
councillors that vote is now showing in
blue if you would like to cast your vote
thank you
councillor lindsay
can i take your vote please
counsellor lindsay can i take your vote
thank you
um chair that is 24 votes for that is
unanimous thank you
that is carrie
thank you
appointments
are there any changes to places
placings
council award
thank you so
thank you all for attending uh this
council meeting
the next meeting will be tuesday the
22nd of march
at
5 30 p.m here in the council chambers
thank you
i all play